howdy is one of the most recognizable
luxury car brands in the world along
with mercedes-benz and BMW last year
they sold a total of 1.8 1 million cars
around the world but this is actually a
14% down from the previous year so why
are all details down and what does their
logo even mean
make sure stick around till the end to
find out welcome to Hari salaries so it
all started when an automobile company
named Michael Hoffer and Yannick was
established in 1896 in Chemnitz Germany
a Winkle hopper and Yannick they
originally started I have motorcycles in
1902 but also out of automobiles in 1903
they created the wanderer brand at 90th
lemon to use with overseas exports but
soon after this brand name was also
adopted for domestic sales as well by
1926 they were producing 25 vehicles per
day and they were doing pretty well but
this will all change with the Depression
of 1929 they were forced to sell their
motorcycle company to Frantisek Yanis
Tech in 1929 and 1932 they also had to
sell their car division along with their
factories to Auto Union around the same
time in 1916 a Danish engineer named
Jorgen Rasmussen found another a lot of
a book company in joke house Saxony
producing steam fittings tried to build
a steam-powered car this was
unsuccessful but he was able to make a
two-stroke toy engine in 1919 he
slightly modified an engine and put in a
motorcycle which he called desk knob and
whoosh which meant boys wish later he
placed a das decline wonder which meant
the little wonder and this is how the DK
EE brand was formed and by the late
1920s ekw was the world's largest
motorcycle manufacturer around the same
time on November 14th 1899 Akash
invented a company augustson see an urn
fell to Cologne in 1902 he moved to
Reichenbach in bachlin and found her a
joint stock company named August and C
motor wagon work of aeg but he had
trouble with the CFO and so in nineteen
he decided to create another new company
he created August horse automobile work
AG we had to change in England company
as horse was re-register branded on a
25th of April 1910 he change the
company's name to Ali Auto girl work AG
howdy was the Latin translation of the
german verb Horsham which meant listen
in 1932
both the forces brands Porsche and Audi
merger dkw and wanderer to create the
auto union group of Saxony and these
four companies represent the four rings
on the company's logo and this is how
Dee was born before World War two Auto
Union only used a four interlinked logo
on the racing cars at this time the auto
companies used their own logos and
brands they were highly focused on
smaller cars due to the economic
downturn in the 1930s by 1938 the dkw
brand made up 17.9% of the German car
market because they really focused on
small cars how do you on the other hand
only count for 0.1% of the German car
market in the final few Audi's were
delivered in 1939 and after that this
fan completely disappeared from the new
car market for over two decades during
World War two like most German
manufacturers Auto Union was repurposed
for military tool manufacturing this
made them a prime target for Allied
bombing and by the end of the war they
were heavily damaged and then after the
war in 1945 the Soviet Union over ran
their factories and completely
dismantled them and their assets were
expropriated or taken away with no
compensation the auto union of Chemnitz
was completely erased from the
commercial registrar executives knew
that there was no prospect in continuing
auto unions production in
soviet-controlled East Germany as a
result the liquidated the rest of the
assets and moved to West Germany and
English that of area here they started a
auto union spare parts operation by late
1945 and eventually this became the
location of the new headquarters for the
reformed Auto Union in 1949 meanwhile
the former artifact
in East Germany restart a production and
start assembling pre-war models in 1949
and this is where the infamous re
Trabant originated from eventually the
companies would rejoin but currently
they are completely separate the new
West German headquarters for our union
was created from loans from state
government of Bavaria and the Marshall
Plan alien they were able to read launch
on September 3rd of 1949 and they
resumed production of their dkw
front-wheel drive cars but the economic
boom of the 1960's did not benefit the
two-stroke engines of dkw cars people no
longer had to buy smaller cars and as a
result people switched over to
competitor cars Volkswagen and Oakland
eventually years of unprofitability led
to a decision to sell our union and a
huge selling point for all our union was
it just finished building a new large
factory capable of producing four-stroke
engine cars Volkswagen
after seeing expansion opportunities
with the company decided to buy 50% of
the business in 1964 and after this
purchase both mark and decided to
complete dump the sub brands of auto
union that they're associated with the
true stroke engines instead they
resurrected the name
howdy from 25 years ago they offered the
same cars but with new engines starting
in September of 1965
for example they took the DK WF 1 or 2
fitted it with the four-stroke engine
indeed the F form of sweet and sold
under brand of Audi as the economy was
booming and people wanted more powerful
cars most when they decided to sell outi
cars with their horsepower rating names
this effect is selling up the Audi 60 75
80 and 90 until 1972 when a Wolf's wagon
bought our union yeah no intention of
actually growing the Audi brand they
simply want to expand their production
as a result they forbade outing workers
from further product development despite
this Ludwig Harris continued to work on
the Audi 100 in secret and we showed it
to chief Nordoff he was very impressed
he was so awestruck he also has a
production of
100 which was released in 1968 and this
is how the Audi brand was resurrected
1969 re-emerged with NSU in the 1950s
and the C was the world's largest
motorcycle manufacturer and this created
the company are the NSU Auto Union AG at
this point artists image was pretty
conservative so proposal common chassis
engineer names your bensinger to create
a four-wheel drive car was accepted this
technology was to be used in a
performance car which was later named a
Quattro and released in 1980 it was
really successful and its prominent wins
really proved the viability of for both
cars in racing and this put out on the
world stage for innovative automobile
technology by 1985 the NSU and our union
brands were pretty much effectively dead
and as a result the name was shortened
to out eag but by this time the Audi ad
was starting to develop a grandfather
car image already tried to combat this
by releasing the type 89 and new Audi 90
but this along with basic construction
issues really slumped and RV sales
awesome results in the early 1990s are
decided to change a target demographic
to luxury car owners and start to
compete with the BMW and mercedes-benz
this began with the release of the Audi
v8 in 1990 and this is how D entered a
luxury car market and since the turn of
the century sales for Audi have strongly
grown worldwide deliveries to customers
increased from 653 K in 2002 over 1
million in 2008 major mortgage Ferrari
are Eastern Europe Africa the Middle
East and recently China and this is
because all these the curved choice for
the Chinese government and officials are
given out e cars and 20% of the sales
from China are from the garment in late
2009 I already had an operating profit
of 1.17 billion euros which makes it a
large contributor to the walls backing
group
meanwhile Bentley and Sidra suffered
considerable losses in May of 2000
eleven howdy of America had record sales
mostly due to her new Audi a3 and a7 and
in September of 2012 I'll be opened the
first manufacturing plant in North
America in Puebla Mexico and this is how
RT became the popular luxury car brand
that we know today but recently they
actually haven't been doing so well on
these global vehicle sales were actually
done 14% at the end of 2018 over the
last couple of years there were several
internal issues and big scandals as well
in May of 2014 our dealers in the UK
also cleaned up the Audi a7 a8 and r8
were endcap safety tested never exceeded
5 out of 5 for safety testing but this
never actually happened and of course
there was the Wolf's wagon emissions
testing scandal that happened in 2015
audience admitted that least 2.1 million
cars were involved in the scandal so
what pretty much took place with this
was that software is installed of course
that manipulated the emissions data
which fooled regulators the pollution
caused by these cars were actually much
higher in the government mandated levels
despite these sales Ferrari actually
increased during these years so what
happened so recently well howdee has had
a bad reputation for reliability and
customer service well at least that's
what many online customers say and this
definitely deters new customers from
going to outi and then there are
Japanese makers like Honda and Toyota
car matching if not beating out his load
to mid and quality with cheaper cars
they are able to provide similar levels
of luxury and comfort for a
significantly cheaper price and in my
opinion there really hasn't been that
much innovation coming from Audi over
the last couple of years of course their
self-driving cars but asked for their
most popular cars they're pretty much
the same for the last decade I mean take
a look at the 2010 Audi a4 and the toy
in 1988 form they're pretty much
identical and this gets even worse when
you compare the Audi q7 sure those
internal advancements and slight body
changes but there hasn't been
he's refreshment like the other
competitors other competitors have
refreshed their cars completely several
times during the same time period and of
course outies models are very classic
but that only goes so far and this lack
of innovation I think is one of the most
important reasons that how D slows
themselves through simply no reason to
upgrade to an Mira RT so people might
router new competitor when they're
switching out cars and clearly this is
taking a toll on their sales out he is
one of most classic German car
manufacturers and are really known for
the innovation and luxury recently
however their cars lacked
differentiation from cheaper Japanese
cars and have somewhat stagnated in
terms of luxury and groundbreaking
technology and this has led to a
worldwide decrease in sales but
regardless Oddie is such an interesting
history as the whole brand is complete
is continued and suddenly bought back 25
years later and today re has meant to
themselves as an iconic brand and often
a fan favorite hopefully already will
continue to innovate and push the
boundaries but only time will tell
but that's why I hire you as an Audi
make sure comment down below what
company you would like me to cover next
also if you guys liked this video they
may drop a like and consider subscribing
if you like to see more videos just like
this one but go then I'm Hardy I'll see
you guys on the next one